[Music]
in worse time to come out News 0:01 it
submitted by slinky the wiener dog oh my
god I didn't mean to point it at your
face all I picture when you say is this
big lump [ __ ] sticking out of here
[ __ ] Schwartz right now there's a
vein right I know but the way he says it
like it like it like this it's like a
[ __ ] big ass beam that's coming out
of my [ __ ]
I had a hemorrhoid in college because I
pushed too hard when I was [ __ ] I
think that's what happened then POW and
I didn't know what that was and I
thought I had anus cancer you guys are
really comfortable with that thank you
what's wrong with that honesty is the
key it makes me feel better when I get
to express it because there's nothing I
can do about a hemorrhoid
you just got to vent it out not mean
like it's just fiber water and like what
did you say cream anal cream yeah that's
that's all you can do there's nothing
there's no pill I can take to make it
smaller there's no immediate fix like
it's just gonna take time you know yeah
kids don't push so hard when you're
constipated you'll get a vein that'll
pop out of your [ __ ] ass it's not
like a chapped lip we're all it's not
like a chapped lip we're all you can use
a [ __ ] lip balm and then it's all
better this is where we put in the plug
for like anal cream brought to you by
brought to you by head are those
hemorrhoid cream
house of cards has been cancelled after
sexual harassment allegations have been
made against why you're not wrong it
happened over this way yes you [ __ ]
beast wars I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're watching strength war thank the
Lord
stupid ass piece Wars before
so what's going on guys
wow you know this whole rumor and stuff
these stories have already been well
known in the industry for a long time
it's just now the public knows but
people are in entertainment knows of
Kevin Spacey's freaky ways from faculty
that if you are a good-looking straight
male or gay male on one of his projects
you're almost guaranteed to be flirted
with Florida dwith all flirted with yeah
in a in a non inviting way so is Kevin
Spacey of the yes you know kind he's you
didn't know that no I didn't know that
he just came out with it though but I
think what he was saying all the insider
like everyone's been knowing that he's
also why big cancel I'll tell you why
this whole thing what would you like to
do my job from you and it's on those
three it's a juicy story you know you do
alright so the actor I'll do it go ahead
no just kidding start I just wanted to
do that alright so actor Anthony Rapp
he's 46 years old he was the first
person to come out with these
allegations and he did it through an
interview with BuzzFeed so oh what a
great publication great actor great
actor artist I'm a big fan of his work
yes his actions
I like his impressions honor that one
show he did Christopher Walken he did
the the something show daily show John
something back in the day damn bro like
watching somebody fumble through garbage
I like him for the weirdest movie it's
k-pax I think he did a great job acting
like a alien that's what he's known for
albino or not no no his eyes are blue
okay so you came out saying that after
seeing the Weinstein allegation surface
that he felt that he needed to shine
another light on decades of behavior
that have been allowed to continue
because of many people including himself
have been silent this whole time but now
that he now that all this is coming out
he wants to be able to shine light on
Kevin Spacey and so what he's saying
he's claiming that Kevin made advances
towards him back in 1986 at a party when
Anthony was 14 years old and Kevin was
26 and so he had picked him up placed
him on a bed climbed on top of him and
like he was just like just trying to get
it on with this 14 year old he's a
rapist and a pedophile yeah yeah so then
um so this is what Anthony looked like
around that time oh you got low
standards dude these are well-known
stories of what he does quite petter
rapists pedophiles do um do it in my
mind everybody is an angel
yeah so then after these allegations
came out Kevin's basically came out with
this statement would you like to read it
Kevin Spacey impression impossible I
can't do that I'm just I don't want to
butcher him well maybe after this I'll
find out yeah I have a lot of respect
and admiration for Anthony Rapp as an
actor I'm beyond horrified to hear this
story I honestly do not remember the
encounter it was already starting bad it
would have been over 30 years ago but if
I did behave then as he describes I own
this a sincere apology for what would
have been deeply inappropriate drunken
behavior God and I am sorry for the
feelings he describes having carried
with him all these years the story has
encouraged me to address other things
about my life I know that there are
stories out there about me and that haps
that that some have been fueled by the
fact that I have been so protected of my
privacy as those closest to me know in
my life I have had relationships with
both men and women
oh wait what what's the other I have
loved and had romantic encounters with
men throughout my life and I chose now
choose now to live as a gay man I want
to deal with this honestly and hopefully
and then and that starts with examining
my own behavior so there's so many wrong
things here in this whole statement like
a lot or gay people pretty mad about
that very mad they're so pissed because
of the connected raping to a homosexual
it's mainly the pedophilia with
homosexuality because they're saying
that they have gone through decades of
trying to remove that stigma or not
Sigma but that what is it yes thank mo
okay yeah that's big money that like
gays are pedophiles cuz apparently back
in the day a lot of people would draw
that conclusion and they're just like we
worked so hard to remove ourselves from
that and now this fool coming over here
just like connecting them again that's
wrong the fact that he says that he now
chooses to live his life as a gay man is
also asset to the face of the gay
community and so a lot of people are
just really upset about this whole thing
I mean I'm not try to give him the
benefit that maybe he just wrote that
really poorly but it did really spot a
PR team it really it really did sound
like he was connect those together
coming out I don't think he was trying
to connect it I don't think it was just
like I think it was like poorly written
let's let's put let's cast a shadow over
the big issue by me saying I'm coming
out because he wanted like what gay
support means that what I wanted
probably let's change the topic kissed
the guy when he didn't want to a
fourteen-year-old boy you're 26 and by
the way he was freaking hideous at 14
yes what's your style why you didn't
just come out and deny it like most
people are like I didn't do it and then
when all the evidence is presented
they're like all right before him he's
like whoa that story I will remember if
it did happen
I was probably drunk and it was yeah
he's like admitting to it almost
I do it all the other times but that
time though I don't remember that one
haha so you guys don't drink is that
baby dick every now and then come on
this which fourteen-year-old are you
talking about
which fourteen-year-old because if it
was that one I clearly didn't touch him
not one always drunk
the other ones always sober man that's a
really bad apology do yeah well if I was
drunk maybe but what's the reason behind
that man that's a little he goes by the
way guys imma let you know right now I'm
gay it's like what why why now why do I
now do this how my that's when people
started tweeting out like he just
invented a new thing which is like the
worst time to come home like there had
never been a worse time to come before
except now is there like do you guys
believe in like if artist is so good
that we should excuse some of their
actions like yes I do
wait wait what like for example like
excuse your action yeah like Kanye West
would you excuse his retardedness it
reduces behavior for him though it's a
Michael Jackson Dave Chappelle yeah
great great let me let me let me clarify
something though uh when you're seeing
excuses behavior do you mean as as a fan
excuse it or as like in a court of law
like to get a path and a court hopefully
both some time no not in the court of
law in the terms of fan fandom yeah yes
because I I still like Michael Jackson I
don't know if the allegations are false
or they're true but because I am a fan
of his art I'm like cool I like your I
don't give a [ __ ] about you as a person
even with my blood like artists and so I
feel like it's just something separate
although what if no what if somehow they
don't they can't prove this yet but what
else what else
scientifically they are able to prove it
takes a little bit of crazy to be a
great you got a lot of phlegm I know a
little bit of crazy to be a great then
then if we want greatness in the world
this is the evil that it comes with do
we accept they can continue their great
is behind bars like they can pay your
debt to design society they can still
create music or all that [ __ ] but
then they still have to be accounted
they have to be inspired you have to be
inspired
but why other people's expense that's a
[ __ ] up that's selfish as [ __ ] so so
in your guyses world then in the
scientifically proved if they're
scientifically prove that that means
anyone that gets to good we should
already immediately start examining
where do you have crazy pedophilic or
whatever behavior kind of like that no
what you're saying is celebrities are
above the law that's basically what
you're saying yup and that's not what
I'm saying what I'm saying is if it's
scientifically proven then as a society
cuz we choose our artists you know we
choose to want Lady Gaga to be here we
all buy her album right we all vote
together so if it's scientifically
proven that greatness comes Michael
Jordan comes a little bit of crazy then
us do we want to dilute what our human
ability is just so everyone could be
safe or do we want to seem crazy as in a
one encompassing thing but because crazy
isn't just rape this and that the crazy
is also just socially weird socially
awkward you know and those aren't those
are criminals a non-criminal ones do it
non-criminal crazy you know I mean it's
like I but I do agree though because
every time I meet an artist that I
really admire like from a distance and I
don't [ __ ] insane they make me look
normal
you know what I mean and it's I don't
know I don't think I'm crazy enough to
be an actor that's what I think is cuz
like the best actors they're so [ __ ]
weird like even Bobby Lee right like you
see him you see him in his skits and Mac
on MADtv and you see some of the stuff
that me and Joe made and they're like
possibly Bart and Joe are way crazier
than Bobby but that's just because we
control all material then you meet us in
real life and you're like Bobby is
[ __ ] crazy as a [ __ ]
me too are boring yeah we're boring as
[ __ ] compared to him his sketch version
of himself is the watered-down version
of his real you know so now I could
imagine people that are even better than
him they're probably even crazier than
he is even more
balance so for me to answer your
question I would say if it's at the
expense of anyone else no I think you
know but Michael Jackson Michael Jackson
is but in the board of law he should be
tried I know but if he came to my
country he could have as many kids as he
wants I'm against pedophilia but there's
an exception okay Michael Jackson is
[ __ ] dope never a [ __ ] exception
there's a lot of orphans out there that
need lovin okay can you clarify because
I think I'm not following your digging
up a hole here if Michael Jackson feeds
on the blood of [ __ ] young boys to
make his music I will [ __ ] personally
get those kids to donate blood and so he
could drink that much just blood that's
all you if he needs to [ __ ] bite the
anus of a child for him to become a
musician
he deserves it he deserves it then
you're down to give him your own child
yes it's Michael Jackson oh [ __ ] pop
out five kids so three of them could be
normal and two of them will be donations
to Michael Jackson if it was still alive
today
you don't know what I can love Michael
let's be realistic
you guys are crazy you want all the
benefits of these crazy artists but you
don't want to do any other sacrifice
that's like going to war okay like you
got to give yourself up to win but for
war people volunteer to that [ __ ] I'm
volunteering my children it's Michael
Jackson let's hear what the defendant
has to say
I liked this is it I watched a movie I
wanted to go to this concert just
because but I'm more like giving back
like hey you were a big part of my
childhood you gave me a lot of hope and
imagination you made me feel great
let me give back to you alright so back
to so they're a three men that have come
out so far accusing him of sir so for
example there was a Mexican actor named
Robert Robert Cavazos Cavazos and he
wrote on Facebook that Kevin had groped
him in a bar in London that he walked
over to him and just grabbed his entire
package those are the type of stories I
hear yeah and then also another
filmmaker Tony Montana same thing a guy
named Dan deal who was approached by
Kevin Spacey back in 2010 when he was 19
at a bar in London and he whipped out
his dick and in order to keep him quiet
he gave him his watch that's worth more
than $6,000 and then after he gave him
his watch because this guy he worked at
the bar that he went to in a hotel and
then after Kevin Spacey like the next
day he had his people call the hotel and
say like this guy had his watch and the
guy was like oh no I lost it but in
reality he had already sold it it's been
like they were like he just kept
harassing him and and I can't even asked
him like hey do you smoke weed let's go
to my room I got weed and he just kept
like trying to lure these people out so
these are the men this is the Mexican
actor all he's an actor I was like
what's the Mexican been doing in London
issue that should make no sense no that
wasn't a different he looks like a
bootleg train spotter guy this is the
guy the guy that worked at the bar that
got to watch yeah you got a watch from
Kevin is it that watch yeah
I'd suck his dick for a nice watch where
you think he's all dudes I'm coming you
know just kidding that's the other one
the other volunteering kids and then
another now after all this people are
looking at his exact acceptance speech
when he won the Oscar for American
beauty and he this is part of his Beach
quote to my friends for pointing out my
worst qualities I know you do it because
you love me and that's why I love I
loved playing Leicester because we got
to see all of his worst qualities and we
still grew to love him so a lot of
people are now speculating like oh he's
talking about himself because the
character Lester in American Beauty he's
like the creepy guy going after his
daughter's friend and so now they're
just drawing connections there and also
next Netflix has announced that their
they have suspended production for
season six of house of cards and now
they have to review the allegations and
obviously began they were already saying
that the season six was scheduled to be
the last season of this show so it's not
because of Kevin that they're canceling
it
I agree I don't know I what's been
sucking have been the first three
seasons of house of cards were just they
were next level like they were like wow
it's it's what put Netflix TV shows like
produced series on the map and then our
election happened in our actual real
politics were more entertaining then it
surpassed this [ __ ] yeah boy it got
boring and you know you know what's
interesting is someone I saw this meme
where they're comparing Donald Trump
with Weinstein right my thing is going
through this yeah it was like they had
the same exact criminal you know type
activities you know but then one was
elected president one was pretty much
fired from his entire life and I just
thought that was that's interesting if
you a hundred percent support Donald
Trump I think you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
only because hey not even thinking about
his policies I'm thinking him I think
he's just like old and senile you know I
think like he's all I know David but I
gotta be so mean everyone knows I'm a
closeted trumple over I guess it's not
so closet anymore
he's just so senile like isn't that I'm
not even talking about like on the
pullet I'm just talking I think he's
like lost his mind
like to believe it's a tactic like he's
being the [ __ ] male bimbo like Paris
Hilton yeah me being hopefully thinking
that I'm like yeah I think he's a genius
oh there's something last straw was him
just cooked because because he comes up
and then he's like telling everybody
that he his wife wishes that she was
here right now she's right next to my
wife says you her best wishes she wish
she was here right now at her face girls
he forgot that his own wife was right
next to him on stage I was like oh he's
lost his mind
what what if the president work is
really hard because remember how Obama
came in looking fresh and then all of a
sudden he got gray hair and hasn't been
a year yet hope you guys enjoyed that
episode of JK news make sure to stay
connected because we're constantly
updating our social media so follow us
at JK films for Instagram and at JK
films for Twitter to watch more videos
click right over here
[Music]